[Music]
Mission Impossible it's back and this is
Mission Impossible week on CBS mornings
the new installment of the movie series
is Mission Impossible dead reckoning
part one and it is already getting Rave
rave reviews we're talking to its star
performers for our mission impossible
week here at CBS mornings and we are
kicking off the week with fan favorite
Rebecca Ferguson playing former British
MI6 agent ilsa Faust for the third time
in the series in this clip Tom Cruise as
Ethan Hunt finds ilsa hiding in the
desert while on the Run
[Music]
Ethan
foreign
Mission Impossible we are proud to say
is from Paramount Pictures the same
company as CBS and Rebecca Ferguson
joins us now Rebecca thank you very much
for being here thank you Bravo and Bravo
yeah we've all seen it we all love it uh
you just said while the clip was playing
that you don't do Mission Impossible you
live Mission Impossible what do you mean
by that good slogan though but it's so
true because you asked me do you train a
lot of weapons and I think
God I lived it we woke up you train you
eat well you do weapons training because
you have to be ready for something that
you don't really know what it is yet
yeah yeah so fight shoot and look good
doing it you know something else you
also said is that this is Mission
Impossible on crack yeah yeah that's a
strong description
bright and early let's get right to it
listen we saw the movie and from the
very jump it grabs your heart and it
holds on to it it doesn't stop it
doesn't stop stop so why did you
describe this movie like that and how is
it different from the others I think
I think the crack thing sells itself but
I'm going to move away from it I think
when we promote Mission films we know
what to expect with writers and Tom
Cruise I know is going to be incredible
it's going to be intense it's going to
be action-packed but I think this one
emotionally action wise goes beyond I
didn't know what to expect because I
didn't really know the movie until I saw
it yeah so I think one of the best
compliments that Chris told me he got
was that I bought a seat
but I only used half of it I bought a
seat but I only used half of it because
you're sitting at the edge of it yeah
that's that's why yes yes yes
um you know the other thing that I think
is so interesting we've all Rave about
the stunts we all know the stunts we all
know there's going to be running we know
there's going to be action-packed but I
think that I think people don't
understand that Tom in addition to
stunts really focuses on characters
doesn't he I think something that I love
and something that we don't it's not
about talking about we know he does the
stunts but to be on set and have this
scene that is explosive and dynamic and
have Tom at a moment go but wait a
moment can you explain the character
reasoning for this well they stop the
shooting stop oh there's a moment
there's a something needs to be figured
out it's not just we'll get it done it
is we need to understand why this is
character driven we all focus on so much
of the stunts but what you don't see is
the sort of the the description of
reasoning and the dark plots and
character and we need to earn the
moments that you see yeah you know Glenn
Powell's told us I heard him say that
working with Tom Cruise has influenced
how he does acting how he does movie
making how he treats human beings
has do you have similar stories about
that about working with him as a child
around your work and I just you know
free fall into meetings now
do you know I I do I'm
I'm a part of a production uh that I'm
doing right now called Silo and another
a TV show on Apple yeah yeah yeah and uh
I'm so aware of how Tom would run a set
and it's not him as a boss so I guess
that's the word it's the collaboration
Tom brings the best yeah every single
day
and he expects the best and not in a
hard whipping kind of way just in a you
have been given a platter yeah of
training of knowledge so give it when
it's given and I know that I expect the
same yeah on a show that I produce I
want the best and so you know it's not
just the Steins it's not just the action
it's not just the story it's actually
the emotion that you guys are able to
create on on screen you bring together a
collection of some of the best actors in
the world and you're following the
script you're hitting your marks but is
there room to kind of improvise at times
I mean yeah we have Simon Peg on set so
okay okay
actually yeah you are yeah I mean
you should ask Simon I think they did an
interview oh this is good I can't do the
quotes you have to ask okay okay and
he's supposed to talk about Milana about
the White Widow and he says something
about to drop of a pin out of an orgasm
he whips out like little quick beats
like that which are just constantly in
movies they're not scripted it's just
him it's so great to see you and you and
your characters together because there's
always a will there won't they um
Dynamic to your relationship and that
continues in this movie yeah
I think why is that important
and I'm sitting there going go ahead go
ahead maybe that's why I guess it's sort
of the is it the Heathcliff thing the
the kind of the what keeps them apart
that is what I find attractive and
interesting we never Tom and I am a
queue we never talk about them as an
item but I guess when we watch the film
they're so similar they fight the same
cause and yet you know you have Elsa
constantly saying but why yeah why are
we doing this we could run away
you know there's there's so much
connection between them but is it
sibling family love yes what is it it's
so much more it's Humanity you must be
so excited about this movie coming out
where it's got rave reviews already
people are saying I can't wait to see it
what's it like for you knowing that
people are going to see it this week
what are you thinking
I mean it's
it's not just people people I mean yeah
yeah it's quite daunting it's daunting
it's exciting I think also it's that
treat of giving an audience something
that I know that I Loved Before I was in
it yeah I've waited for Mission
Impossible wow I loved them well it's
it's a treat having you here people are
gonna use half their seat when they
watch it because it delivers Rebecca all
week we've been marking the release of
Mission Impossible dead reckoning part
one with many of the film stars
including one of the franchise's most
popular characters on Monday Tony and I
spoke to Simon Pigg who played Ethan
Hunt's right-hand man Benji Dunn and
five Mission Impossible movies here's
our interview with him starting with the
clip of Benji leading Tom Cruise's Ethan
into one of the most exciting and
dangerous action scenes of the entire
series
I must have made a wrong turn somewhere
no no that's it that's it why how could
this be it well you can see the train
right
yes I see the train what about it and
you have a parachute had a parachute
who do you expect me to do well just you
know
jump just jump yeah have you veggies
doesn't work like that I'm not that high
there's there's Ledges sticking out
everywhere I'm gonna hit them before the
parachute even opens even if I could get
the parachute open I don't know if I can
make it across the valley and intercept
the land safely on a moving train
coffee yes I copy look I'm just trying
to help you okay I need you to take a
step back and pull yourself together
because I am under a lot of pressure
right now
Mission Impossible is from Paramount
Pictures part of the same company as CBS
in the legendary Simon Peg joins us
right now how you doing hi fellas I'm
really good I'm very very happy good
thank you for subscribing to a very bad
day there you were having your character
having an okay
yeah no doubt about it and and that
scene comes right before Tom's big
motorcycle jump yeah take us on the set
that day was it as chaotic as it seemed
actually it was the opposite of chaos
really Tom is very very diligent when it
comes to preparing for these things he's
not crazy everyone says oh he must be
crazy he does you know but he trains
hard everything is in place it's a
well-oiled machine we were up there just
to see it I was doing my offlines for
the bit when he comes to the edge and
then we stayed up to watch it happen and
it was day one you know day one of the
shoot day one and you could either see
that as us sort of like starting as we
mean to go on you know set the standard
or just in case it doesn't work we don't
have to shoot a whole load of the film
and then start this is your friend and
your colleague many years now yeah what
was it like seeing him go
it was scary we were all a bit
hysterical because I mean we trust him
and we trust the system We Trust
everything involved it's not like you
know the the sort of uncertainty is
minimal but still it's it's
nerve-wracking and he would disappear
and then we'd wait and there'd be a big
sort of pause and then you'd hear a good
canopy which meant his shoot had opened
at least yeah still had to get down to
the bottom so it was yeah it was
exhilarating to say the least wow you
actually did pull out your phone
yeah so what was going through your mind
as he was toppling over I was I was
looking at movie history being it was
movie history right this is the biggest
stunt not only in the franchise but one
of the biggest stunts in movie history
you know and so I thought I better
capture this for a posterity and um and
in case the other cameras fail we have
one shot where we got it on the iPhone
don't worry guys I got it I got it on
the phone yeah yeah yeah that's great oh
man so you were you came into the
mission impossible franchise uh at the
mi4 mi3 wow that's a long time ago it
was and he was a kind of lab technician
at the time and JJ Abrams had called me
I thought it was a nice little Cameo I
was gonna have a little you know I go in
Hollywood and then I go home to my dogs
and everything will go back to normal
but here we are five films later so I
know you're working with a script uh but
then you have these scenes like there's
one you're dismantling a bomb wall like
toss it off one liners I've got two
buddies high stakes how much of that is
predetermined and you're just delivering
the line and how much room is there for
you to just have fun because you know
these people oh yeah yeah well Chris
McCrory is is always really Keen for us
to to invest ourselves in the characters
and to to throw stuff in
and he's an oscar-winning writer so we
the script is amazing but there's always
room in the moment to kind of Chuck in
little asides and you know I mean you
never know what you'd be doing what
you'd be saying when you're diffusing a
a an artificially intelligent nuclear
bomb so yeah in the moment things come
up you know that you throw in I want to
ask you about the villain because it's a
little unusual yeah villain in this
movie yeah um how would you describe
well when I was told about the idea of
this this entity this sort of self-aware
kind of computer program that that uh
Eastside Morales are brilliant sort of
like human villain is is working at the
behest of I thought that sounds very
Mission Impossible it's a bit sci-fi
Mission has always been about new
technology and but in the time since we
started shooting to now the notion of AI
has become more and more prominent in
our sort of social discussions and it
feels incredibly pressing there speaking
of existential threats potential Mission
Impossibles you're on strike right now
uh with the writers yes uh there's a
possibility that the actors may go on
strike they're not too distant future
uh these things need to be worked out or
there is no more Hollywood there's no
more entertainment exactly what are your
thoughts in general uh on the strikes
well things need to be fair you know
things need to be Equitable and the the
infrastructure needs to be adapted to
accommodate the new the new ways we
watch film and TV streaming and you know
the tech companies need to understand
that that
for things to continue everyone needs to
be treated fairly and as soon as that
gets sorted out and it it will do
hopefully things will be okay but we
can't face another
content drought next year you know we've
only just got back on our feet where
everyone's only just back in the cinema
if everyone's next year is ready to go
and there's nothing to watch that's
that's going to be a terrible thing so
we need to just talk sensibly and get it
all sorted out I'm curious to get your
opinion on movie making filmmaking and
also artificial intelligence you know
when we keep it in the back of our mind
what's going on with the writers
the only thing AI can do is create
mediocrity because all it can do is
aggregate what's out there so it yes it
can write a script but it'll be rubbish
you know what I mean AI has had no
childhood trauma ai's never had a
boyfriend or a girlfriend never had
heartbroken you're spot on it's never
been through anything that would give it
the the the impetus to create art when
it has its own personality and its own
experiences it can write a film about
what it's like to have nobody but at the
moment it can't do that and so to rely
on it would be to just make everything
mediocre and what we have to fight
mediocrity in order to create great art
I know that sounds lofty no no that
might be one of the best answers I've
ever heard yeah that's the idea of AI
hey Simon Pegg we appreciate you joining
us you're one of the most versatile
thank you so much good luck moving
forward lovely to be here thank you
Mission Impossible dead reckoning part
one is in theaters now go see it one of
the Summer's most anticipated movies
have you seen it Mission Impossible dead
reckoning part one it's in theaters now
and all week we've been talking with the
movie stars for a mission impossible
week the movie is from Paramount
Pictures part of the same company as CBS
go as we sat down with actor Palm
clementieff here in the studio just
yesterday she joins the franchise as a
ruthless and deadly Paris she is tough
in this clip from the movie Paris
Corners Tom Cruise's character Ethan in
a narrow Alleyway in Venice Italy here's
a look
[Music]
is your heart racing just looking at
that yes we are very happy to say first
on CBS mornings at Palm clementieff
joins us in studio and after looking at
that scene they say that people use half
of their chairs in the movie because
you're sitting at the edge of your seat
which is so true and that certainly is
one of those scenes we're told that
during that scene in particular you said
did Tom kick me kick me kick me harder
it's kind of true but I have to explain
okay so you understand the thing is I've
been training for years and
um so I know my distances and I know
that if I squeeze my abs I can take a
hit so that's what you do when you fight
you know yes
um and Tom is so trained and so skilled
and so good at action that he could
actually do it if he wanted to and a
little bit of contact in action movies
actually helps and makes it look more
real and it helps in the acting too
because if you hit me a little bit oh my
eyes are going to change and I'm going
to become a tiger so I was just asking
for that because I thought it would have
helped but he's such a gentleman that he
was like no no no father I'm not gonna
hurt you I'm not going to hit you I was
like just just a little bit please no he
said no but this is what the director
says about you I love that little
antidote that you are a self-propelled
force of nature your nickname was Palm
Cruz
So Physical but it is fascinating your
backstory you wanted this role for a
very long time that you trained even
when you didn't have the role so it was
my dream to do action movies but
specifically Mission Impossible because
I think it's the best of this genre you
know it's more than just an action movie
I think it's art you know and the level
of excellence in in everything in these
movies is just you know it's just
mind-blowing so years prior Mission
Impossible even before getting cast in
gardens or a Galaxy Vol 2 I started
training martial arts so someone called
Jessa novello taught me how to cake how
to punch uh how to do stunts how to do
that on camera and all the tricks you
know it takes years to be good at
something to be better you know so
you're always learning I'm still
learning now but
um back then I was training and even
sometimes in my schedule I would write
Mission Impossible in my phone instead
of writing martial arts training or
stunts manifesting it was manifesting
the whole time was like one day I maybe
I get to do a fight scene with Tom who
knows he's ready and you did and I said
kick me please uh the you also Manifest
this character Paris who is she pursues
Tom with a kind of maniacal Glee I
should say Ethan Hunt in in the role and
and I was reading that you found
inspiration for this predator in animal
videos but particular kinds of animal
videos right it was a stork of some kind
yeah no it's a crazy prehistoric bird
that looks crazy and I like the way it
moves and the look that it has and in
the movie as you know I don't speak a
lot so a lot of emotions are conveyed
with just body movement face movement
with just you know a kind of like a rage
boiling Under the Skin and wanting to
explode but like with no words you know
so this this particular bird you have to
Google it it's called shoe bill or shoe
build sork I thought it kind of looked
like my character it cannot look like me
a little bit
yeah you've got it for sure and and you
and Tom clearly have a deep respect and
a great working relationship now uh at
the premiere when he called introduced
you on stage they had a they had an
introduction for all the cast members uh
they were saying pom pom pom pom pom pom
pom pom pom pom using your first name
they call it mission in Palm impossible
yeah
no no ever no that's so cute they were
like doing that on uh when we were
shooting the movie they sometimes I
would just sing
come on guys you know what I would do
sometimes what
um before an action scene or
specifically before
um you know when I had to run on top of
a moving train it was going pretty fast
you know just and to remind myself what
I was doing and how happy I was to be
shooting this and to give me more
courage to do it I was like
yourself wow yes and then running on top
of the train
um uh jumping over carriages and and all
that I was reading that Tom as a kind of
a rap gift when you were done shooting
this film he gave you uh uh skydiving
lessons yes and you're using them yes
completely so he set it up for me which
was so kind and so generous and I
learned how to skydive I stayed there
for like 10 days I took lessons and um
and he did some jumps with me we did oh
yeah there was so much fun that's cool
and now I'm hooked and as soon as I have
some time off I go back to jump you must
be so psyched though about this movie
I'm I'm so excited for all of you guys
everybody that's come here this week
because it's such an iconic movie and
now you will be associated with it
forever yeah I mean to go from someone
who dreamed about it to really that
coming true what does that mean to you
uh it's a it's a huge honor you know and
I'm I'm proud and I'm very happy to be
working with Incredible filmmakers like
Christopher McCrory and Tom Cruise who
you know so so amazing to work with you
know and who inspire me every day so
yeah if you're lucky we are cheering you
on thank you thank you so much thank you
so much for being here
it's Mission Impossible week here at CBS
mornings and there's a potential fight
around every corner
it's all about the stunts in this
franchise and these fight scenes they
don't happen spontaneously
in fact it takes days weeks months even
years sometimes of careful planning and
the focus is all on safety so what I did
[Music]
I caught up with the film's director and
visited a stunt training center to see
if I
could hang with the professionals
if you know anything about Mission
Impossible you know this
the stunts
in every new movie
[Music]
without fail
seem to be bigger and better than the
stunts in the last
[Music]
and when you see Tom Cruise dangling
from a plane
the director makes darn sure you know
it's really him to challenge normally
when you're shooting an action movie is
you're always trying to hide the fact
that it's a stunt man and not the actor
in Mission Impossible it's the opposite
you're you're trying to show that it is
Tom and not a stunt man Christopher
macquarrie has now directed three
Mission Impossible films part of a
15-year plus collaboration and
friendship with Cruz I like to describe
it as one long conversation about movies
that's occasionally interrupted by
production it began ahead of their 2008
Thriller Valkyrie when both read a
professional Crossroads and Macquarie in
particular was thinking of leaving
Hollywood the only reason I was thinking
about leaving the film business is I
didn't really have a a creative partner
I didn't have a creative net and that
was our very first meeting was talking
about the kind of movies we wanted to
make why we make movies and Tom was some
who was very straightforward about I
make Mass entertainment in the
relationship when it comes to the story
and the stunts yeah who pushes whom
we're pushing each other I think we're
pushing each other we're challenging one
another when you work with Tom you find
yourself doing things you didn't think
you were capable of doing
where other actors would happily allow a
trained stunt double to step in Cruz
who's also a producer of the series does
the stunts himself
and that's even after breaking an ankle
on a leap between buildings during the
filming of MI6
[Music]
sense of just how demanding these stunts
can be hey hey how are you hi Tony man
nice to meet you Tony I met with Stephen
Keffer who's made a living performing
them on TV shows and films including the
John Wick series he can really do it all
Judo Jiu Jitsu so a lot of
throwing people around he now throws
people around at his stunt training
facility in New York
where he told us a good stunt always
starts with a coherent story so it's not
to do cool for the sake of cool okay I
could do a backflip here yeah I think
you know I can do it yeah meanwhile
you're an office worker who's never
trained anything in your life but all of
a sudden you're doing it yeah they're
like yeah we don't need the backflip
right so part of our job is to really
collaborate with the writer and the
director to make sure that the story
that they want to be told is being told
and that's part of the secret in Mission
Impossible there is a design behind the
danger but let's also be clear the
danger here is very real and when it
comes to Tom Cruise so is the talent
behind it I have massive respect I know
how hard it is to do the things that he
does you know it's it's just overall
better if the actor can do it but how
hard is it really
I mean could I do it today we actually
choreographed a fight for you yeah so
we're gonna warm you up okay get you
nice and loose okay and teach you to do
a fight scene it took about two hours to
prepare for my little scene learning the
fake Falls
the punches nice and the knife tricks
which does make you understand how hard
this really is and that it took
thousands of hours of planning and
training to pull off a movie like the
latest Mission Impossible look at all
the marketing that went into Tom
Cruise's motorcycle stunt and
parachuting and like that's a big part
of what sells the film now is that it is
Tom Cruise doing it and we can do bigger
better and on and on and on and on
because that motorcycle stunt scene
alone has drawn so much attention ahead
of the release of dead reckoning part
one we asked Macquarie to explain it to
us this is Tommy's on a ramp and we've
replaced the ramp with a uh with CG
landscape that's the only that's the
only digital element in the shot but at
this point he that's real air real Tom
Cruise real motorcycle that's real Tom
Cruise real motorcycle real clouds
now this is taken from as a separate
tape where it's Tom and a cameraman and
Tom doing actual dialogue in free fall
where's your heart and mind at that
point um it's very much an out-of-body
experience it's life and death stakes
and it's it's it's very very real you're
very you're you're what we call in
present time
[Music]
the acting perhaps could have used some
work oh I'm crying out loud
I actually picked up on the choreography
pretty quickly oh
if you're ever looking for some cross
promotion
I am available for Mission Impossible
dead reckoning part two
and for whatever Tom Cruise and Chris
McCrory can come up with next
again that is a real Tom Cruise real
clouds real air real motorcycle real
free fall there Mission Impossible dead
reckoning part one is out in theaters
everywhere today we should remind people
but take us back to that Tony did you
enjoy doing that number one we should
say this to Rica that they had blocked
off four hours for Tony to do it and I'm
told that you mastered it in two I did
manage to do it too I had a lot of help
from Paul varachi who was my uh my
fighting partner there on Steam Kepler
they got a great studio uh but it gave
me a A Renewed appreciation uh for what
it takes to do serious Real Deal Mission
Impossible level stunts you know if
you've got 200 plus million dollars to
spend it takes years of planning
actually to do it two hours for my you
know average uh fall through a few boxes
also like to try to remember the lines
and the story and all that while doing
the choreography it's an incredible
blend I mean I have so much respect for
what they do and for what Tom Cruise
does really Klaus had a great joke Klaus
you know I love Klaus here so that's
that's Tony
this thing with you in the beginning was
Brian Jarrett and who else that was very
clever oh yeah it was Brian uh and Jared
uh and uh and Max yeah Max was the
Unseen Punch
Yeah Yeah nicely done guys nicely done
that was fun that was a fun piece that
music can only mean one thing it's
Mission Impossible week yes please today
is a day Mission Impossible dead
reckoning part one finally hits theaters
so all week as you know we're talking
with the stars from the new movie this
morning it's Vanessa Kirby's turn she's
returning to the role of Alana mesopolis
better known as white widow a powerful
and dangerous International arms dealer
in this clip She lays out the stakes of
Ethan Hunt's latest mission
as most of you I am merely a broker I
connect a buyer and a seller sometimes
for money sometimes for information but
mostly for friendship
I just want everyone to get along
with me especially
but
the world is changing
truth is Vanishing
war is coming and the key to World
Domination is of all things
a key
one that any government in the world
would pair King's Ransom to take
possession of
and some of my dearest friends in this
case every major nuclear power and a
handful of minor ones have asked me to
deliver this key
that is such a good scene such a good
thing wasn't it Tony mission impossible
as you know by now is from Paramount
Pictures we're very excited about that
because it's part of the same company as
CBS Vanessa Kirby welcome welcome
welcome we are so excited to have you
that scene is probably the center of the
movie I mean that pulls it all together
and you carry it off so well
I think this movie has certainly lived
up to the hype and all the Press I just
want to open with this yesterday 24
hours on Tuesday Tom and your director
Chris visited movie theaters in Toronto
DC Atlanta and Miami and one day they
went from City to City just to say thank
you to the audiences they posted a thing
saying see this movie in any movies we
thank you for coming then they just kick
back with some popcorn and some uh soda
just to say thank you to everybody yeah
Vanessa you two have been making the
rounds but today is a day and I'm
wondering how you're feeling because it
really does live up to the height
yeah you ready for it
um like yeah it's always a different
experience you know when something I
mean we shot this in the height of
covert and we were a little bubble and
it was over many years and we were in
that senior reference there was all the
characters the key characters very rare
and these Mission films to have
everybody together
um and everyone was wearing masks and
Tom was one of the first people to sort
of pioneer being able to shoot during
covert and so because we were a little
family in our bubble for it now to be
out there in the world is really
thrilling and I think everybody is so
fantastic in it and I'm very proud to be
a part of it what I so love about that
scene and you and the film in general is
the quiet intensity you know you have
everybody's everyone's looking at you
and hanging on your ever word but you're
not yelling you're not fighting people
in this film
um you're very menacing and threatening
and scary without raising your voice
without any big movements yeah it's it's
incredible uh and what's interesting is
that Christopher Macquarie the director
uh told us that he finds actors he wants
to work with and then builds characters
around them so were you part of that
building process how did that go yeah I
joined them at the the them about yeah
six six and a half years ago when we did
Mission Impossible Fallout the previous
one and one of the first things they
said was we love having a kind of um a
thread between the movies that started
30 years ago with the first mission
possible and Vanessa Redgrave he's one
of my heroes
my mum yeah and Max and so I was so
lucky because I got to study her and she
had this incredible I've never I would
never have thought of it myself to be
somebody that's sort of so in charge of
this really dark you know hugely
powerful organization but to to do it
with lightness and play rather than as
you say being you know assertive or
menacing I mean I was very tempted I
think I came in quite strong start that
way though being very aggressive yes and
what did they did they tell you dial it
down or what yeah they said try playing
with it remember that the most powerful
don't need to assert it because she
doesn't have to if you said I mean and
so it was a big acting
um Challenge and also lesson and it was
it was was wonderful to learn that
actually you can do it quietly you know
you have said that Tom Cruise has an
unhinged thirst for Perfection so I'm
wondering working with him do you feel
because he always seems to want to kick
things up a notch did you feel for
yourself the pressure of wanting to kick
things up a notch for yourself
stretching yourself the interview Tony
just did with Chris he says Tom as you
doing things you didn't think you could
do yes did that happen to you as well
yeah I don't remember saying that was
quite good quote yeah I am
it's a bit like I was there as a Tom
if you see this incredible stunt the
motorcycle and I know he's posted about
it um
someone anyone daring to do that and
take the risk of doing that and move
through the fear and do it eight times
when you we were there watching on set
watching them do it and he was the lead
he was the calmest person by far but
when you watch him do it and you realize
what's the equivalent in my own life
what are my most what would I be most
afraid of I mean that would terrify me
but how could I push through that and
you know do something that I didn't
think that I could do before and if Tom
can kind of do it in front of you
perhaps I can and so for that reason I
think it kind of is very inspiring for
for all of us around him because you
just think what are my limits or what am
I most scared of and then yeah that's
right your character is also sometimes
we don't know what side she's on
yeah I think um again what Vanessa
Redgrave did so well is oh God she was
so Charming with Tom wasn't she and he
sort of loved each other in those in
those scenes and um I wanted to yeah
just try and capture the essence of what
she had done really do you read you were
at the premiere you were saying with
your dad in London what's it like with
family members watching you on the
screen in this role I remember that when
we went to Fallout the previous movie
and I sat next to my dad in the huge
IMAX Tom had done a big screen in the
IMAX
and it was so sweet Turning to my left
and seeing him
look like a five-year-old you know just
completely all his facial expressions
were incredible and he was jumping out
of his seat and popcorn going everywhere
and he was just adorable and so yeah
it's really special when you go oh God
you we know what it's like to be there
filming the scenes we know how long it
takes we know the different edits and
the you know the the the time and over
the course of many months but yeah to
have people experience it that you love
is is pretty cool she has a very quiet
way of speaking doesn't she she does
it's mesmerizing yeah oh yeah yeah we're
all right I said I think it's the seat
oh no no you look fantastic I'm really
excited for you really excited for this
movie and can't wait for people to see
it thank you thank you thank you so much
and you're already working on the next
one we all yeah yeah Thomas has done a
huge big sun sequence in Africa they've
been filming for months are you really
remarkable yeah not allowed I think I
might be told off but she's in it thank
you Vanessa Kirby thank you
CBS mornings at 8 30. you know what that
music means the next mission impossible
movie is almost here and we were talking
the stars of this long-running franchise
for our mission and possible week we're
calling it Haley Atwell joins the cast
in Mission Impossible dead reckoning
part one she plays Grace and expert
thief in pickpocket who finds herself in
the middle of a high stakes mission in
the clip you're about to see grace and
Tom Cruise's character Ethan race
through the streets of Rome
[Music]
looks like that
[Applause]
race again pull over
pull over listen I'm trying to help you
Chris Grace was looking out for Grace oh
Grace was looking out great uh Mission
Impossible we are proud to say is part
of uh Paramount Pictures which is the
same company as CBS and first on CBS
mornings we are very happy to welcome
Haley Atwell here Haley thank you very
much for being here having me uh so you
were just saying as we were watching
that clip that some of those lines were
in the moment they were improvised yeah
we obviously we knew choreography wise
what the car was going to be doing and
what the dynamic of the relationship the
characters would be but there were so
many opportunities where they would say
just just try stuff so sometimes when I
was handcuffed to Tom though I'd have to
work out when he spoke to me whether he
was telling Hayley slow down or take a
left or if it was Ethan speaking to
grace in which case I didn't have to
slow down I could take a right instead
you know so it was it was exciting and I
think that's probably why it feels so
exhilarating watching it because you're
in the moment alive yeah how much
preparation went into learning how to
drive and the scene we didn't see which
is just after the one where that
accident happens you guys are hand
cuffed to a steering wheel and you're
kind of taking turns driving the vehicle
yeah isn't it isn't it I mean it was so
endearing and funny to think that of all
things Ethan Hunt is undermined by a
Fiat 500 but when I when I saw that that
was a little yellow car yeah that you
pick up exactly and it had a mind of its
own so this the steering wheel was so
sensitive so there's a moment where you
know he turns the steering wheel and the
car just crashed immediately we're like
oh okay I guess oh can we yeah for
clarification those who don't know
um Tom is actually driving right yeah
there's an assumption that when you see
stunts and you see car chase you're on
the back of a trailer or something
you're being rude oh no we we and I'm
I'm drifting too I mean an answer to
your question I trained for five months
with an incredible team led by Wade
Eastwood to make sure that I knew how to
drift competently but then you learn how
to do that on a race track in the UK but
then when you get out to a location like
Rome these all these other moving
obstacles and so it it you know it
elevates the stakes even more wow so I
had to practice a lot you know Haley the
premier as you know was last night and
you you had one of the prettiest dresses
in the room I'll just say that about you
but what was so endearing to me is when
Chris the director and Tom came out one
of the best introductions when you say
Tony said we don't call her Haley we
call her hail yeah that she's that good
what she does this is Tom speaking is
extraordinary and terrifying impressive
in every single way and Chris reached
out to Tom and say we have to find her
we have to get her that's the person we
want at the time they weren't even quite
sure you said what the character was are
you not afraid when you're doing those
things and if you're not afraid of
family members afraid for you
yeah I mean I I was scared watching I
know it's a movie you know yes I when
when I did it we thought well let's have
Grace be afraid that feels that's human
that's real if she'd been slick and cool
and the stakes wouldn't have been as
high for her so if you would have sort
of been like oh she finds this easy so
we just kept using all of that you know
my both my parents have seen the movie
my dad was at the premiere last night my
best friend my cousins and they were
just like how do you do that I don't I
don't know it was you just do yeah you
display so many layers of your talent in
this film
um not just with the stunts but you're
acting as well you know you're described
as a master pickpocket
um so you still your wallet the key or
your heart which it seems like
as viewers but also Ethan's heart in the
film but what is it like you have in
your skill set your talent and then
working with a legendary man like Tom
Cruise do you learn from him do you pick
up things did you take anything away oh
it was it was a master class really in
not only work ethic and his
incredible manners he's so gracious and
so polite to everyone and hard-working
but then also his understanding of every
technical aspect of filmmaking so he's
very inclusive you know he invite us to
production meetings he would ask us to
watch playback to look at what the frame
was communicating and he's always
thinking objectively for the audience so
this whole film was designed going does
this Engage The Audience does it make us
Retreat from her lean into her so all
the way you're just finding watching him
he's finding moments of going how can I
excite and Delight the audience did he
want to know how you all were doing too
during the scene how you're feeling yes
to be very caring in that way to me yeah
he's he's very um attentive he also can
kind of read people so there's one part
of the film where there's a train
Carriage sequence that goes from
horizontal to Vertical yes seconds yes
and I'm hanging from it and I think it
was like our fifth take and I was kind
of we're waiting for the train to reset
so we could do it again and I was like
obviously jumped in the corner kind of
looking quite tired and he was like how
you doing it's like I I don't even know
at this point Tom I don't I don't even
know what I don't know
no but I don't know he went I think you
have adrenal fatigue and he presented me
with this beautiful box of chocolate
like out of nowhere and said he
presented you he was like you need some
chocolate that's going to wake you up
did that make a difference yeah I mean
it's going to make a difference to my
life in anything so so Tom Cruise is
doing these stunts with chocolate in his
pocket and now I bought us something
fall out of his pocket when he came out
of the motorcycle yeah I remember when
that train scene is amazing it really is
yeah it's amazing yeah and how are you
feeling this movie's coming out on a
Wednesday which by the way I've never
seen a movie come out on a Wednesday
when it's already gotten such critical
Acclaim how are you feeling about the
rest of the world that gets to see it
you excited about it nervous about it
what are you thinking I'm excited big
I've seen the movie myself five times
and it's because it's just so good and I
feel you know we're so proud of it but
even the whole filmmaking process every
single frame and scene was designed
executed edited with the audience in
mind and you know when I said to Tom you
know what is the running time of this
gonna be and he said it's going to be as
long as it is entertaining wow
that's such a good sign yes and it's
true it goes by so far you guys have
been working on this movie for how long
I came on four years ago four years ago
she learned martial arts uh had a thrift
pocket had a drift yeah don't run a car
to this lady
you got a lot of skills going forward
and we got a part two coming next week
you guys are filming that right now
right we are yeah we're about 30 and
we've got a long way to go the Simon
press tour is the kind of uh this is
your rest period right yeah and Simon
Pegg said part two is gonna make this
first one look like Elementary School oh
yeah this is a setup for the second one
this that this is like an introduction
of what is going to come next I can't
wait yeah Hayley at well thank you very
much if you like action movies Haley but
you do so much more than action movies
yeah I'm classically trained so I did a
lot of theater I still do a lot of
period dramas adaptations of books
independent movies limited series and
then I kind of find myself in a
franchise I'm like okay it does it all
yeah
Mission Impossible dead reckoning part
one a complete movie unto itself really
great out in theaters everywhere
tomorrow